Donald Trump's indictment is based on 37
felony counts related to mishandling
classified documents obstructing justice
making false statements some of those
actions under the Espionage Act which we
will dig into later as we continue our
Deep dive into this the Hillary Clinton
email controversy was based on
allegations that she used a private
email server for public Communications
this was deemed extremely careless by
the FBI it was not deemed Criminal by
the FBI because it did not appear to
break the law that's what we care about
the Trump indictment says Trump shared a
classified map
related to military operations uh with
people who were not qualified to see
that he knew that it wasn't Declassified
because he said after leaving office
this is classified he improperly stored
boxes containing classified documents by
his toilet in the Ballroom in the shower